>> IT'S A GOOD DAY WHEN ONE OF
THE BIGGEST NEWS STORY IS ABOUT
A TWEET THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
YOU CAN ADD TO THE TRUMP
COLLUSION THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
EITHER.
OVER THE WEEKEND A PROFESSOR
TWEETED THIS QUOTE ATTRIBUTEED
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP:
KIM JONG-UN IS SMARTER AND WOULD
MAKE A BETTER PRESIDENT THAN
SLEEPY JOE BIDEN.
YOU COULD HELP HEAR TRUMP SAYING
THAT WHICH IS THE PROBLEM.
TOTE  TWEETERS BELIEVED AND HE
SAID IT WAS A JOKE AND TOOK IT
DOWN.
THIS TURNED THIS TINY STORY INTO
A SEGMENT.
IF IT'S NOT CLEAR IT'S A PARITY
IT'S JUST MISLEADING.
AND IT'S ON MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND
WHICH NOTES THE SACRIFICES OF
THOSE WHO DIED FOR OUR COUNTRY.
MAKE SURE IN THE FUTURE YOUR
COUNTRY'S BLOOD IS TREATED AS
PRECIOUS.
WE MUST BE DOING BETTER IF OUR
MILITARY FOOT PRINT AND
SHRINKING AND THE WARS AMONG
ADULTS ARE OVER TWEETS.
2 YEARS AGO WE WORRIED ABOUT
MISSILES FROM KIM AND NOW IT'S
ABOUT FAKE TWEETS HEADING TOWARD
HIM AM THAT'S PROGRESS FOR NOW
ANYWAY.
I THINK THE PROBLEM WAS IT WAS
PLAUSIBLE.
>> YES.
>> HE IS A BIG POPULIST.
>> I READ HIS BOOK AND WANTED TO
THROW IT AGAINST THE WALL.
AT THE END HE WAS FOR
NON-INTERTENSION.
>> YOU LOVE WAR.
>> I BELIEVE IN BEING THE
POLICEMEN OF THE WORLD.
I SAW PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TWEET
EARLIER.
I SAW THAT OKAY.
WHATEVER.
IT COULD GO IN MY FANTASY BOOK.
>> YOU HAVE A FANTASY BOOK!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> ARE YOU DRESSED UP AS A
POLICEMAN?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE SO GOOD.
>> TWEETS I NEVER SENT.
AND TWITTER.
>> EXACTLY.
JESSE, I FEEL SAFER NOW THAN I
DID WITH NORTH KOREA.
EVEN WITH THE TWEET.
IT'S DUE TO TRUMP'S NATURE OF
DEALING WITH SEPARATING THE
PERSON FROM THE COUNTRY.
HE DEALS WITH THE PERSON WHICH
IS WHAT SALES MEN DO.
>> I THINK IT'S FINE THAT THE
SO-CALLED EXPERTS FALL THE
HOAXES AND BLAME THE HOAX
INSTEAD OF THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE NOT AS SMART AS THEY
ARE CRACKED UP TO BE.
THINK ABOUT EVERYBODY WHO IS AN
EXPERT FELL FOR SMOLLETT AND
FELL FOR THIS.
IT'S A WEEK OF CHECKING
SOMETHING AND THEN YOU GET ON
THE BOTTOM OF IT.
I DON'T GO ON TWITTER ANYMORE.
I DIDN'T GO ON TWITTER ONCE THIS
WEEK.
>> WE TOLD YOU NOT TO TWEET
ANYMORE.
>> THAT WAS YOUR INTERVENTION?
>> WE WERE TRYING TO HELP YOU.
>> THE FIRST SUCCESSFUL
INTERVENTION THAT EVER HAPPENED
WITH ME.
>> IT'S TRUE.
WE TOOK HIM IN THE GREENROOM.
>> I TOOK TWITTER OFF SEAN
HANNITY'S PHONE IN 2015.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN A JOURNALIST
FOR MANY YEARS.
ANYTHING THAT SEEMS TOO PERFECT
NEVER IS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S THE REST OF THE STORY.
I AM SURPRISED IN THAT
CONVERSATION IN THAT LAST WEEK
TRUMP SUPPORTERS PUT OUT WAY
DISTORTED VIDEO OF NANCY PELOSI
LOOKING LIKE SHE WAS DRUNK.
PEOPLE HAD TO SAY THIS IS NOT
REAL.
>> YOU DON'T NEED TO DISTORT
THOSE VIDEOS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> BUT THEY WERE OBVIOUS.
>> OH, THEY ARE OBVIOUS.
>> I NOTICEED IT.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE COMPLAINING
ABOUT PROPAGANDA.
>> THAT'S RICH, JUAN.
>> YOU ARE COMPLAINING ABOUT
FAKE NEWS.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
WHEN PEOPLE PUT OUT STUFF LIKE
THIS --
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> GREG SAYS ON THE SHOW, HE
FEELS SAFER WHEN YOU HAD TRUMP
REPUDIATING WHAT HIS OWN
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR JOHN
BOLTON SAID.
>> I THOUGHT YOU HATED JOHN
BOLTON?
>> I DON'T HATE JOHN BOLTON.
WHAT ABOUT THE PRIME MINISTER OF
JAPAN?
>> HE IS PLAYING CHESS AND THEY
ARE PLAYING CHECKERS.
>> I NEVER HEARD THAT BEFORE.
>> I JUST COINED IT.
>> TALKING ABOUT NIXON'S DOG.
>> KENNEDY, THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS.
BREMER IS HELPING THE PRESIDENT
WITH TWEETS LIKE THIS.
YOU NEVER SEE THE ONION PUT UP A
FUNNY HEADLINE AND GO THAT'S
PLAYSIBLE.
-- PLAUSIBLE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
IT SHOULD BE SO OUTRAGEOUS, BUT
HE PUTS SOMETHING IN THE REALM
OF PLAUSIBILITY.
SEE, WE TOLD YOU.
WE HAVE TO IMPEACH, IMPEACH,
IMPEACH.
YOU ARE ONLY HELPING HIM.
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM IS PEOPLE
WILL CONTINUE TO DIVORCE THE
PRESIDENT'S ACTION AND
PERSONALITIES FROM HIS POLICY
AND RESULTS.
THE MORE THAT HAPPENS -- THE
GREAT DIVORCE, THE BETTER THE
PRESIDENT'S CHANCES ARE.
IF YOU RUN AROUND SAYING
EVERYTHING HE DOES IS
SYMPTOMMATIC OF HIS INSANITY --
>> OH, YEAH, KIM JONG-UN IS
RIGHT.
JOE BIDEN IS A LOW IQ FOOL.
WHAT, THAT'S OUR PRESIDENT?
>> IT'S BRIDGING DIFFERENCES.
>> OBAMA DID THE SAME THING
ABOUT TRUMP.
>> I WANT TO SHOUT OUT.
I HAVE BEEN RIPPING UP CNN.
JAKE TAPPER SPENT MEMORIAL DAY
TWEETING OUT MEMORIALS OF FALLEN
SOLDIERS.
THAT'S ONE AREA WHERE YOU TAKE
THE CEMETERY FORMALITY AND
TRANSFERRED IT OVER TO THE
SUPERFICIAL TWITTER.